you are our Canadian gem Canada the
world is so excited about your new music
you new album a world tour sad that Las
Vegas residency is coming to a close
how are you feeling right now this
chapter this moment in your life I feel
amazing mm-hmm
I feel very strong yeah very strong
because I I know what's on my album I
know what we're getting ready with the
tour yeah and it's gonna be the best one
of the things you said is that you're
doing collaboration with SIA so I have
to ask is your collaboration with our
Canadian boy Drake I could see you
rapping I could see you doing hip hop
you know you can 88 right you see a lot
of things guys you still see things best
friend what kind of journey will fans go
through listening to this album courage
you know it's not gonna be like a
shocking album that people would say
well right my my my my journey through
music and my evolution through music is
just to get different essence is not to
become another person what has been done
has been done and it will be always be
part of my repertoire but it's okay to
try things it's okay to to to explore
and to try things and it I think it's
gonna be one of the most exciting I'm
very proud of this album and the tour
will reflect what the album will be and
they were still tweaking and still we
were so excited I'll see the story
speaking French you know but you don't
want to hear that I'm not very good at
that one of the things I wanted I told
myself if I met you anytime soon to say
thank you for being such an inspiration
I remember when you used to create those
PSAs
about bullying and you talked about your
own experiences yeah now you're 51
you're an authorial spokesperson and I
went into this world about Celine Dion
and I found this picture of you when you
were young knowing what you know now
what would you say to yourself at that
age I even think that then that picture
I was already in the business and you
could see my Chi I had lots of teeth
problem elastic and pulling and braces
and all that and at the time it was not
perfection the technique was not that
great and because I was going to be
because this the album went to the roof
quick yeah and I was going to be on TV
so they really do alter braces to the
maximum very quick so all my teeth were
moving so I was on a liquid diet because
I couldn't chew anything because they
did to Excel normally it takes like
months you know you do
one little twist you know but I had to
look as my best as possible
that's not bad it was even worse than
that the teeth were very very high and
twisted and all that and listen of
course it's not pretty
of course it's not a good picture but
when you look at a picture of someone a
picture of you you have to look through
the picture because the person that I am
today is so happy and it's me yeah
it's who I was I started like that I
cannot reject my past because my past
gave me my present and my hopefully
future
so it's touching for me because I see a
lot of heart in that photo not my best
picture but it's a true picture you've
done carpool karaoke and you talked
about driving your truck around when you
do the tour is there a song that you
like to sing to or listen to while
you're driving when I Drive I drive
people crazy so I try to focus on the
road but I love to listen to music yeah
I mean my new discovery right now that
I'm very hooked on is LP LP yeah let's
see is amazing I'm addicted to see ya
and in LP she's got her own little
fierce look and the range of her singing
and it's just amazing yeah and you're a
fashion icon I love what you wear I love
your style I love your press I love your
confidence all of that with the choice
all about that you know about confidence
but you have to have a team that you
trust hmm so Pepe Munoz and Cedeno Pez
my two stylist they bring me options and
I know that you were there's where that
they present so much and they go they
work so hard they know me so well and
then my friends on top of that so when I
got and when I pick with them what I
love of course I'm confident so you're
gonna pick the stuff with and I don't
mind if people say we didn't like this
we didn't like that we saw the broad we
didn't say there she's got a brother no
bro whatever their heels and the way
that what is that the menswear I don't
care I wear what I want to wear yes I
want to party like a believer yes you
look hot
I'm not hitting on you you just look
thank you
[Laughter]
you